We haven't covered this yet, but you might be wondering, what about zeros in
fractions? How do they happen, and can they happen? Let's look at some squares
to figure this out. Here, I have a square broken up into four equal pieces.
Notice that none of them are shaded. That's okay.
I can still have 0 out of 4. For fractions, the numerator tells us the number of
equally sized pieces we have. The denominator tells us how many pieces our
whole, in this case, our square is split in two. Notice that I have none of them
shaded. So, I have 0 out of 4. Since I have no pieces, it's really just 0, 0
divided by 4 is 0. For this square, it doesn't make sense to split it up into
zero pieces. I can't take a square and divide it by nothing. It just doesn't
make sense. Fractions with zero in the denominator are undefined.